hier soir vers 16 heures plusieurs coups
de feu ont été tirés à proximité de
l'école maternelle picardie aucun impact
de balle très certainement des tirs
d'intimidation
mais deux heures plus tard deux hommes
ont été blessés devant cet immeuble
l'un aux jambes l'autre à l'abdomen
depuis le 22 novembre six personnes ont
été blessées par arme à feu à planoise
le trafic de drogue serait l'enjeu de
ces règlements de compte
il existe on traite les roms est très
clairement une lutte de territoire il ya
des personnes qui ont été arrêtées par
la police
il ya des prises de saisie très
important de stupéfiants qui a été fait
sur planoise les dealers donc sont
actuellement donc j'imagine emprisonné
donc et parce qu'ils se sont dit mais
libéré il ya donc une lutte de
territoire la population ne veut pas
être là au milieu
l'arrivée de 15 policiers sur le
quartier depuis un peu plus d'un an
les enquêtes de police et de justice ont
certainement déranger des trafics selon
le préfet du doubs 204 personnes ont été
interpellées et 12 points de deal
démanteler la restructuration des bardes
d'habitation pourrait aussi être un
facteur déclenchant des rivalités les
appartements aujourd'hui qui sont
laissés vacants ne sont pas renouer à la
location par les bailleurs donc
effectivement ça donne des appartements
qui sont vides et qui sont susceptibles
des deux côtés même si les bailleurs
aujourd'hui font le nécessaire pour que
ces appartements ne le soit pas face à
l'urgence
la préfecture annonce le déploiement
d'une unité de forces mobiles
une centaine de policiers dont la
mission sera aussi de rassurer les
habitants
je pense que ça peut dissuader mais
au-delà de ça y'a à planoise et à
touille à l'éducatif y aller donc
cannois site éducative reconquête
républicaine mais ça faut mettre les
moyens en main
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec les
habitants qui voudront bien travaillé et
nous mercredi des associations
organiseront une marche et appelle tous
les bisontins et en particulier ceux des
quartiers plus paisible à se montrer
solidaires